[Music]
hi everyone thanks so much for joining
us today how are you doing today we're
gonna be talking to you about growing
your app on GCP first I'd like to
introduce Asha Asha as a developer
advocate
Audra loves Ruby dinosaurs robots and of
course cats and this is Myles Myles his
developer advocate on the cloud team
with me he's also the director of the
node.js technical steering committee and
he loves music and getting dim sum with
his tech friends in fact earlier this
week we stumbled across dim sum randomly
on the Google campus we had to pause our
rehearsal so we could have dumplings
before we could continue I hate them all
so we've spent part of our careers at
startups for both of us we know what
it's like taking an idea into production
and then growing it and adopting it as
your user base shifts we know that
picking the right tools for the job at
the right time is a balancing act of
costs versus benefits versus skill sets
and today we're here to show you that
the Google cloud platform has products
that will work for you no matter what
phase you are at and what your current
struggles are so once upon a time there
was a startup cat fax has anyone heard
of cat fax before raising hands it's a
few of you we might be old miles yeah
this might be an old joke cat facts is a
service for getting facts about cats so
some quick facts about our cat facts app
we already have an MVP we're running on
some provider somewhere in a VM because
originally we were running on my laptop
and we've got some OS and the database
in the app are all running in that
environment because that's how I had it
on my laptop and we're using node
because miles and we're using some no
sequel database because I don't want to
deal with having to keep a schema
consistent and having to deal with the
schema I was we're rapidly iterating on
this thing and we're doing email
integration through third-party use I
don't want to deal with email
so like cats the VMS that we use are a
little temperamental we only have one at
a time it's very precious but it also
you know can get kind of angry if you
try to pet it too quickly and we really
have to take care of it there's no real
rooms when you have a single virtual
machine for errors so Myles is gonna
show us quick what the MVP looks like
because most of you who are not familiar
with the joy that is cat Fox so so as
you can see here we have cat fax you're
gonna sign up for cat facts with your
email address I'm gonna make one up oh
my god cats dot biz
oh my god cats biz we're gonna submit it
now once we've submitted it we've
subscribed to cat facts we're gonna get
a response letting us know that we've
successfully subscribed and then every
single day we're gonna get an email with
a new fact and a new cat with a new cat
fact back to you Asia thanks miles
so our cat fax app wants to move to the
cloud and we're gonna be using GCP
because we're here at Google i/o so what
are the reasons folks might want to move
to the cloud into GCP one of the ones I
hear a lot is that people's investors
want them to investors are familiar with
the cloud and they know that it gives
you a lot of flexibility to grow rapidly
if your app just suddenly takes off and
it's almost so relatively easy to get an
idea of what costs will be the cloud is
known and people are comfortable with it
now you might also want to move to the
cloud because you don't have an ops team
or cat facts up it's just the two of us
we don't really have an ops team and you
might want to move to GCP because you
trust Google you know that GCP is
running on the same hardware and the
same data centers where we run YouTube
and search and Gmail and we keep those
up so we should be able to keep your app
up too so we have a VM to run VMs on GCP
we're gonna be using Google compute
engine this is Google's VM is on the
cloud service and we can pick the exact
combination of CPU and RAM that's right
for serving our cat fax and so I'm gonna
pick something that looks like my dev
box because I know that works so if we
want to move of
/ - a Google cloud platform there's a
couple different ways that we can do it
we can spin up a whole fresh for the M
and maintain it by hand and build
everything up or we can try to find a
way to orchestrate it this can be
through tools such as ansible chef or
puppet or you can have file system
images that you move over but it is
going to be a manual process to move
this over so VMs are awesome though and
there's a lot of things that I like
about VMs you have really fast startup
time so you could see from the second
that you spin up the VM it's gonna be
about like 30 seconds until it's
available ready to use and once it's
running it's available all the time you
don't have to worry about how fast it's
going to boot up after that from that
you can make images and quickly boot up
in the future at any time you can also
customize the spec so you can customize
how much memory you're gonna have how
much CPU you're gonna have and you could
really dial it in if you need graphics
cards you can do that too you need if
you need TP use for doing tensor flow
you can do that it's extremely flexible
you can make it as big or as small as
you want and it's very familiar so if
you know you know the abun - environment
or Windows server you can just get that
spun up quickly and be working in an
environment that you know so there's a
list of stuff to consider here we have
to consider process management security
updates upgrades we need to consider
scaling we have to be responsible for
doing all of those security patches if
something bad happens I don't know how
many of you guys were working in the
industry when heartbleed happened but I
was working consulting at that point and
that was a very frantic morning for us
as we patched a whole bunch of VMs you
also if you're dealing with VMs you have
to do backups you have to disaster
recovery and provisioning and you have
to do database replication and that's
always been my least favorite ops tasks
is database replication and our ops team
is just the two of us and we don't have
the time to deal with all of that stuff
so we're gonna move to highly managed
services and specifically I want to
start with a database because I really
don't want to Tate a base replication so
we're gonna move to one of Google's
types of managed databases where we can
get services like that and some of our
disaster recovery taken care of for us
google has sequel and no sequel options
we specifically have cloud sequel
and our relational model and we support
both my sequel and Postgres and if you
have something that's very high
throughput you need to do a lot of
Rights you need consistency and you need
to be global scale we have cloud spanner
which is amazing it can do so much stuff
and it all those fire lights the cap
theorem but not quite and then we have
datastore which is our no sequel data
which is our no sequel option that's
actually what we're gonna be using in
this demo and we also firestore which is
not on the slide but is part of firebase
and it's very similar to datastore so
now that we have the database moved over
we want to figure out where to run the
application how many people in the
audience have used App Engine before
quick raise our hands awesome so you
know all the amazing benefits about
moving to App Engine but App Engine is
our managed platform as a service we
love Astra we love App Engine because
there's no ops it has integrated
datastore when you deploy on App Engine
you have HTTP already ready for you you
have idiomatic runtimes so I love this
as a node.js developer I can write my
node.js app I can test it locally and
then I can deploy to the cloud it's
going to run exactly the way that I
expect it to run and if I need to run it
somewhere else is going to just work
also all the container images that we
use for App Engine flex are all
available on github so if you want to
fork them if you want to add to them
it's easy for you to do that
so now we've got someone else dealing
with the applicant operations of our app
and we demo for you but the demo for
showing it running on App Engine is
nothing has changed so we're gonna skip
that part
so now we can factor out bits of our app
and add new features which is what I is
an application but it will priya lee
want to be doing i want to make cool
stuff I don't want to deal with pagers
so first thing we're gonna pull out is
your app or app mails you cat facts and
we don't really have to run the mailer
in the front end on the same machine so
my also can tell us about what we're
gonna do next with the mailer so when we
originally wrote this application for
our MVP well as we said we had
everything in a VM the database was in
the VM the single node app did
everything and this isn't super flexible
it's not going to scale nicely
it's not going to have nice abstractions
and it's not going to be reusable so one
of the first things that we decided to
abstract out once we moved over to App
Engine was our cat fax as a service so
we were able to go and maybe Asha do you
want to get into and describe it so what
we're gonna do here is I'm going to show
you so we moved all of our stuff to
cloud functions like mileside we moved
in a mailer and we also moved some other
stuff there but the first thing we need
to do is to build out a function to get
us cat fax so this is some code to
retrieve cat fax from the database and a
picture to go with it you can see we're
just doing some really basic datastore
queries here because and we're ordering
on last used only pulling one thing back
and I've got some code there to update a
timestamp and then we just send back a
very basic JSON payload and a status
code of 200 it really took only about 10
minutes to write this code and most of
that was remembering how datastore and
Java Script work together and miles was
talking about the email so he's gonna go
into the code for the email and talk a
little bit about how we approach that so
part of the reason why we decided to
move the email er to a cloud function
was because email is not a service that
is running in hot code it's not going to
necessarily affect the user experience
so and you saw the demo where I signed
up with my email address I want to get
the response from the server giving me
the confirmation that I've signed up we
do that once your email addresses in
datastore but once that's done we don't
need to wait for an email to go out to
actually send a confirmation to the user
so we send a message out on pub/sub to
send an email and we have this generic
email server that creates a client and
sends a request with the data to that's
who the email is going to from that's
who is emailing it the subject and the
body and this can be actually reused
throughout our application so the exact
same cloud function is running to send
an email when you subscribe and it's
also sending an email every single day
whenever new facts go out and buy some
by splitting it out into a cloud
function it's able to scale up with our
load as we have more people subscribing
it's able to be used for different
things and it's able to be its own code
that we can think about independently
and if we ever want to change our email
service for example we could just change
the cloud function as long as we adhere
to the same API the rest of the services
don't need to change at all
and so we talked about adding new
features and one of the things I wanted
to add was a catfac spot because I
really like chatbots they're a lot of
fun and our team uses hangouts chat
which is super cool and so I've written
hangouts chat BOTS and one of the
interesting things is that both the
mailer and the BOTS use the same
underlying cat fax service and all the
hangouts chat bot does is it reformats
the facts in picture payload into the
forum that hangouts chat requires all I
have to do is call out to the to the cat
fax service get a fact back and then
send back a 200 with the JSON package
the exact way that hangouts chat expects
it and I had a chat bot it was really
fast and really easy and because it's
running in cloud functions if a hundred
thousand people hit my hangouts chat bot
to get their cat fax at the same time
it's fine and if no one's using my chat
my cat fax chat BOTS because no one
wants cat fax right now that's also fine
cloud functions will scale automatically
to what I need at the time and so I
really like because I don't know if cat
fax is gonna take off maybe people don't
want cat fax in their chat BOTS but
miles who can actually show you that
that chat bot right now and you guys are
gonna see pictures of my cats so here
you can see we are in hangouts chat and
we've got a chat going with the bot and
I could go like hey bot give me a cat
and the BOTS gonna think about it for a
second it's making a call to the cloud
function it's getting the data from the
cloud function it comes back with a cat
and a fact that each cat and owner have
their own unique vocabulary and we can
message it again hey more cats flocks
and we give it a second to think about a
new cat and a new fact and it gets back
to us with the same cat and the same
fact and that's how you know that this
is a real demo back to you Asia so what
happened there is we have we had a had a
time out I did not actually sufficiently
put enough time in my chat bot so you do
the update on my query because we're
trying to pull them up least recently
used
spend some time to barking that
yesterday but I'm sorry I did you guys
saw the broken version but you know it's
real so miles can talk a little bit
about the architecture that we ended up
with and then we're going to talk about
one of the last compute options you have
available in GCP so we've been talking
through all these different services but
we thought that this diagram would kind
of give the clear idea of how we
architected it so we have an a front end
that's written in nodejs and express
that's running on App Engine that's
taking user requests and when you sign
up it's adding a user to BigTable and
then it's requesting a cat fact from the
cat fact function and then it's
submitting an event to to pub/sub to let
it know to send an email pub/sub is then
triggering the function that's listening
for a new email events and emailing it
out now the task scheduler is another
another App Engine app if you didn't
know you can actually make cron jobs
using App Engine to set it up to execute
App Engine rest calls based on certain
amounts of time so the task scheduler is
set to run on a daily basis every single
day it gets the list of all the people
who have subscribed and then it sets a
new task in the pub sub queue for every
single person to send them a new fact
the email er goes and grabs the cat fact
and sends it out what's really cool
about this too though is you'll notice
that we have multiple services calling
to the cat fax service so we have the
chat bot which is also calling to the
cat fax service and we can build a whole
fleet of services regarding cat fax
depending on the kind of service you
want to use to use it we can make
emailers SMS chat BOTS IRC BOTS and they
can all use the same micro service that
can scale up based on how much load
there is maybe we find out that people
don't like email anymore and we need to
pivot to SMS we're ready to do that and
we don't have to do much refactoring to
our actual architecture in order to
support that so at this point let's just
pretend that cat fax is the new hotness
and it is wildly successful and we have
hundreds of millions of users getting
their cat fax and cat pictures on a
daily basis so if that happens which we
hope will happen we're gonna be able to
hire someone to help us with operations
and when I've talked to my friends at
work in operations one of them said that
we need to consider Google Cooper net
I was talking her about it and she said
that it will give us more flexibility
with our architecture while retaining
many of the [ __ ] benefits of App Engine
and cloud functions and it would
specially work well for us because we've
already moved toward a micro-services
architecture with a bunch of different
scalable components so so you may be
asking yourself what's a kubernetes how
many people in the audience have used
kubernetes so far so you're not asking
what's a kubernetes but for those who
haven't kubernetes is is the Greek word
I believe for helmsman governor helmsman
one of those and it is a service that's
open sourced it's in the CNC F the cloud
native compute foundation and it's for
orchestrating and scaling docker
containers in production it's a way of
setting up cloud architecture and it's
designed them based on the Google
internal architecture bork so a lot of
the lessons and things that we've
learned about making scalable services
we're all used to inspire the
architecture of kubernetes on our next
slide we're going to show what a Yama
file looks like for kubernetes and I was
going to tell you about that here's an
example kubernetes deployment file for
engine and nginx container the big thing
to be aware with its kubernetes and this
is the thing that a lot of folks find
challenging at first is that you done
like when you're setting up VMs and
you're doing scripting to make your VMs
reproducible
all of that's focused on the how you
want to install this thing and then this
thing and then you want to change these
ports and you want to set up this kind
of load balancing kubernetes you need to
describe what a happy wonderful good
state is for your product this many
versions of this container this many
versions of this container this kind of
load balancer and then what Cooper
teddies does for you is it does
everything in its power to keep that
happy state so if one of your nodes
magically one of your VMs gets hit by
lightning in the center of your
datacenter it could happen kubernetes
will take what was running on that on
that VM on that node and it will put it
to other places anyway to make sure that
your app is as close to that running
state that happy state that you want it
to be and it takes a little bit of work
for a lot of people to get their head
around the fact that you don't explain
how to get there you use the concepts
that are built into kubernetes
pods services deployments to describe
what a successfully running app looks
like so miles mentioned it a bit in that
example I was actually using the nginx
docker container
uh what's a docker was one of the things
that I asked when people are trying to
teach me about Carol Burnett ease and
docker is it contain it is a container
format in a container is a way of
packaging up a runtime and the files and
the dependencies to go with it and the
nice thing about is you can put multiple
of them on a VM and you don't have to
deal with dependency conflicts like I
know when I was working in ops one of
the things we had was we had like three
different parts of the service different
micro services and they each releasing
slightly different versions of various
ruby gems or slightly different versions
of various c libraries and installing
them together side by side was a problem
then we had to hit like three different
dev teams to actually agree on which
version we were gonna standardize on
with dogger you can just package up an
app with its dependencies and run it
next to an app with slightly different
or very different dependencies on the
same machine and you get much better
utilization and you get safety the other
nice thing about using containers and
docker is that since you're packaging a
container you seem to have less problems
with the works in dev and doesn't work
in prod situation which I know I have
spent many hours banging my head against
and when you read about this you're
gonna see stuff about namespaces and C
groups and all that but the big thing is
running application with its
dependencies and its file system all
packaged it up neatly so what you can
see up on this screen now is fairly
straightforward docker file we're
starting from an image that's actually
published by the node.js project carbon
is the 8x branch for LTS and if you go
from nodejs carbon alpine what that
means is we're gonna grab the latest
published version of a thought exciting
system and alpine is a very very thin
operating system that's been designed
specifically for running and docker
containers if you're looking for fast
boots and thin images Alpine is a good
place to get started we're copying the
file system from the folder that we're
running
in directly into the image we're gonna
run the command npm install production
that production flag makes sure that
your dev dependencies don't get
installed and it's important to run all
of the commands to set up your
environment before you're actually
running in production so this is going
to make sure that all the dependencies
you need are there that there's nothing
in that image that you don't need for
running in production and then the
command npm start is going to boot
everything up so that command gets run
when the docker container has started
npm start is a really great way to boot
things up it's something you put in your
package JSON script if anyone has more
questions about kind of best practices
for setting up node applications please
feel free to grab me after the talk so
one of the things I mentioned in my
definition of docker is C grips and you
might be thinking what's a C group and
that's out of scope for this talk so you
can you can come talk to we have come
there's containers office hours and
there's also office hours on Google
clouds open source projects in the
office hours space and folks from the
kubernetes project will be there if you
want to talk in detail about the
implementation so why would you make the
switch to kubernetes this is the
question I get the most when I'm out in
the field talking to folks at events or
I'm at DevOps meetups and the first
thing I want to say is you don't have to
there's a lot of folks out there were
like kubernetes is the new hotness I
have to use kubernetes and if what you
have works for you great App engines
cloud function App Engine cloud
functions or VMs or any combination of
those like we had with our cat facts app
there are a fine way to run your app
indefinitely if it works don't fix it
but containers provide some advantages
around portability predictability and
utilization and I've seen a lot of
success with teams that have switched to
this the big thing that I've seen from
my DevOps friends is they're getting
better utilization out of their VMs
they're able to use all of the CPU and
all of the memory that they provision
it's less of an issue with GCP because
Google compute engine lets you specify
and make custom VMs that exactly fit
your app but if you have things that are
really variable in load or you've got a
bunch of VMs that all look the same for
whatever reason containers might be a
way to solve that problem and if you've
decided to go with containers for any of
these or other reasons
kubernetes is a great way to manage the
bin packing problem of putting things
there and making sure that everything
stays up I really like that if you
specify known good state and will take
care of making that known good state
maintained for you even if something
weird happens to some of your machines
so some concluding thoughts about all
the things that we just said Google
cloud platform is kind of like a
delicious dim sum buffet and bear with
me on this you have lots of different
options and you can pick them all
depending on your tastes as you need
more they're there they're on the cart
they're steamed they're ready to go you
need more soo-mi we've got more sue my
and it's really easy to share you have
big projects you can add more people to
the projects they can grab the dumplings
that they want Roger now I'm really
hungry yeah as you can tell I think
almost as much about dumplings as I
think about compute but I also like to
not have to think about how I make the
dumplings I just want to eat them and
that really becomes one of the great
benefits about using a platform like
this if you need to focus on your MVP if
you need to focus on the product that
you're getting out of the door and your
product isn't operations you may want to
be just using all these things that are
ready to go you can iterate off of them
as necessary and you can make
architecture decisions to make sure that
you are not super locked into things
that are harder to move but we have a
lot of different products available for
you today to run your compute in all
sorts of different ways based on your
needs so we run through a lot of stuff
really quickly and one of the things I
want to make sure everyone knows is that
you if you choose one of these things it
doesn't mean you can't change your mind
later on all of these things play well
together projects that use a lot of them
are here here's kind of the high-level
summary of what we just talked about so
we've got Google compute on Google
compute engine virtual machines and
custom sizes was talking to someone and
they had done the math and there's over
six thousand ways I think to configure
six thousand different flavors of VM mmm
this is good when you already familiar
with VMs who's shipped something on a VM
I know I have lots and lots of times wow
that's actually fewer folks than I
expected
or if you just want to pick up something
that you're running in a VM on your
local machine and shove it in the soup
reduction we have Google App Engine
a service application platform it's good
when you want a no-ops solution to
running your app and you want fully
managed services you want networking
taking care if you want auto scaling you
want the ability to use images that are
known good that Google has endorsed and
we make sure we're maintaining we're
making sure we're patching and things
like that we've got Google Cloud
functions for event-driven serverless
applications or for event-driven parts
of your application this is good for
tasks that need high scale some of the
time and are largely skate lists it's
especially good if you have something
that's you need to run a lot at once and
not a lot later on because you can shove
as much through that pipe as you need to
or as little it depends on what your
uses and it's really great for that and
then we have google kubernetes engine
and this is managed kubernetes on Google
compute engine this is absolutely one of
the easiest ways to get started with
containers in kubernetes is how I got
started and its really really good
because we take care of a lot of the
stuff for you while there's lots of
folks involved in the kubernetes project
both inside and outside Google Google is
still very involved and the team that
builds google kubernetes engine works
with the team that's working on
kubernetes to make sure that everything
is smooth so we want to say thank you
and before we actually say thank you to
you all for attending I would actually
like to really thank all the folks who
are making this possible we've got
fantastic staff running the lights and
running the camera for the live stream
and producing in this room so if y'all
could give them a round of applause I'd
be grateful and thank you all for coming
and giving us you know 45 minutes of
your wonderful day today at Google i/o I
hope you have a wonderful afternoon
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]